نشرت وسائل اعلام اسبانيه مقطع فيديو
لصاحبي مطعم ياباني في برشلونه يطرد بك
وحبيبته الجديده ويرفض خدمتهما لانه من
محبي شاكيرا
[موسيقى]
انجب مزارع اوغندي يدعى موسى حصحايا يبلغ
من العمر 67 عاما
وطفلين من 12 زوجه واصبح لديه الان في
المحصله
568 حفيدا اللافت انه قرر التوقف اخيرا عن
الانجاب بسبب ارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه كما
انه اضطر لكتابه اسمائهم على دفتر كي لا
ينساها واكد موسى ابقائه جميع زوجاته في
المنزل نفسه حتى يتمكن من مراقبتهم ومنعهن
من هجره
[موسيقى]
اقطع فيديو اثاره جدا واسعا في السودان
يظهر تعرض احد الاشخاص للسرقه من مجموعه
امام اعين المره ولم يهب احد لنجدته نتابع
[موسيقى]
انتشر مقطع فيديو لجو بايدن وهو يتعسر مره
جديده اثناء صعوده سلم الطائره الرئاسيه
خلال مغادرته العاصمه البولنديه وارسو
في ظاهره فلكيه نادره تعامدت الشمس تعامدت
الشمس على تمثال الملك رمسيس الثاني
بمعبده الكبير في مدينه ابو سمبل جنوب
اسوان في مصر في ظاهره يتكرر حدوثها مرتين
خلال العام يوم 22 من فبراير والثاني
والعشرين من اكتوبر وشهد المعبد حضور كبير
من المواطنين والمصريين والسياح لمشاهده
الحدث الفريد حيث قدر عدد الحاضرين باكثر
من سته الاف شخص
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء